[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and this week that person is a
donned a thorn known on the interwebs as
swilley's Woolsey's got over 2 million
subscribers and over two hundred million
views all courtesy of entertaining his
audience with captivating vlog like
storytelling and most often is
accompanied with some sort of flash
animation visual in smoothly he lives in
Florida and we had never really met him
before when we tried to connect with him
before try to get him to be a supernote
captain that didn't really work out we
tried to get him to make a cameo and her
nerve versus geek video because we shot
that in Miami right none of that worked
out for one reason or another but we
tracked him down and then trapped him in
a hotel room at playlist live and said
you got to do any or biscuit with us
we're gonna trap you in a biscuit and I
mean I think you'll just kind of pick up
on the energy in the conversation
because what we were legitimately
excited to talk to swoozie because we've
been fascinated with his content I mean
the fusion of vlogging plus animation
plus comedic storytelling but also he
infuses kind of a moral or at least a
positive message in so many of the
videos and when you put that with the
subject matters that he covers I I would
say in a lot of ways we we very much
studied that and kind of question is
there something that we can do that's
informed by Susie I think that that
comes up a conversation we told him that
yeah and it's almost like he has created
these in this instructional guide for
guys in relationships so many of his
videos focus on these relational
concepts like being in the friend zone
or how to speak female here's a recent
example of one of his most popular
videos called textually active you know
what's annoying people who take hours to
text back especially when they're the
ones I hit you up first like hey what's
up and then you text that like nothing
chillin at you're polite what's you up
to
and they never text you back the next
person that starts text conversation
with me and just leaves me hanging in
mid conversation is
get a loop hang bicycle kick to deface
if you get busy just say in class BRB
and work BRB because if you leave me
hanging don't be looking all confused
when I show up in my more compact plate
because we've got the fight for real
because I know so swoozie pulls from his
own personal experiences and makes them
into his entertaining vlogs I mean but I
found myself thinking this even when we
were talking to him how that story can't
be true it's just too soon that's that's
crazy or sensational or whatever but
when you hear the stories one it's so
entertaining you don't care but I think
the thing that I discover is that they
are true this is just I mean you be the
judge of it on this year biscuit because
he shares some of those stories but he I
think he's just the type of guy that has
experiences that are story tell about
and then he has the skill to do it I
mean here's another example a video
called my girlfriend's boyfriend but
yeah me and my girlfriend we're doing
this long-distance thing for about a
year and then one day she calls me up
and she's like we hire this new guy at
my restaurant named Tim I'm like a week
later on the phone we're talking again
and she's like Tim found out I was a
virgin and he's been like saying oh this
is really sexual nasty stuff to me and
he was like saying how he'd had me
trembling when he was done with me and
I'm like oh yeah put him on the phone
okay so we really enjoyed our
conversation with swoozie and for a guy
who makes a living talking I was excited
that he conveyed to us the he ended up
talking about some things that he has
never spoken about before that's what a
near biscuit or get you okay just a
couple of things to whet your appetite
he talks about his philosophy of the 3
G's God gaming and girls he also shares
a specific crazy story about a hot
mystery girl and a car chase yeah and a
dark suicidal moment in his life that
made him rethink his path forward and
also waiting until marriage to have sex
but licking knee pits in the meantime
here it is our swoozie year biscuit
[Music]
one of your recent videos was about your
ex-girlfriend with the big X or the
little X the big crazy yeah
so it's called my crazy ex right yes
that one so this story is she's trying
to reconnect with you and over text you
guys are setting up a date basically
this American firm to be it and then
when you don't show up I'm the bad guy
and you and then you're - you're telling
Joran you're sharing this whole thing
with your audience so the thing Rhett
and I said was how much of this is true
Oh a hundred I even toned those down i
watered down the majority of those crazy
stories to make them believable and that
one is just like it's so crazy the stuff
crazy follows me first of all
but with that particular story it's just
like I literally was looking at my phone
like how do I find these people to like
this okay hey you want to hang out today
I'm like yeah do you want to hang out at
four and I never hear anything back and
then at four or five they hit me up like
going crazy because I'm not wear that I
can't get mad at you for not showing up
because you never confirmed the same way
you can't get mad at me for not showing
up so yeah she sent me an email
a little bit later saying you know what
I forgive you for not showing up and I'm
like are you kidding me but my question
is she then sent another email once she
saw the video
no she okay she says she stopped
watching my videos okay uh I also find
funny she also said I gave you
permission to start talking about me in
your video so I think she went to my
channel at one point and saw that I'm on
all these other girls and was like I've
been through so much with him and he
never talks about me so she hit me up
saying I talk about her but she says now
she refuses to watch my videos okay
because that was the thing I was which
is good for you it works out yeah I mean
you've got you're able to kind of you
get all this material from the stuff
that happens in your life when people
see the videos that are being talked
about it yeah right so that gets a
little awkward there's one where I talk
about the friend zone and as guys you
know sometimes we know other times we
don't know and then sometimes we don't
want to know but there was a girl who
kept inviting me to her house like to
spend the night and as a co-worker I'm
just
like okay well is she expecting me to
make a move so I talked about in a video
like yo this girl's house at like 12
o'clock I get there it's almost a booty
call if you think about it and then I
would never make a move like we she has
a small little bed the size of a couch
and we're both pressed up against each
other and I never make a move so this
happened this this is real life right
now she closed the door bloody and
there's like she has these big old
drapes over the window so no light is
entering the room pitch-black and we're
literally pressed up against each other
and her beds against the wall so I'm
against the wall and her that's it and
this happened three weekends in a row
she's sandwich two you against the wall
yes and you're just like she made the
move but you're just sleeping that's it
I mean I don't like do I make a move cuz
I don't want to make Moosic ah lights
are on this is uh shutting down
production you know I don't want it to
be like that cuz we've always been cool
friends never any kind of indication
there was no like holding hands or
kissing and cuddling no nothing and she
says you want to spend a night yeah and
so you literally just sleep in her bed
with her it's a 55 minute drive and she
knows it's one way okay video on the 4th
week like yield oh you did it for twit
times you get three times and on the
fourth week I made a veal like guys I
don't know what's going on that it
should I make a move shy not make a move
I got a text the next day from her never
said her name but she knew it was her
yeah she's like yeah is there another
girl that you're just sleeping on our
very small couch with three weekends in
a row that's basically said simply um
you know I'm subscribed to your channel
dot dot dot oh I completely forgot about
this so yeah that's not really the text
that you wanted you kind of wanted
clarification no but what she said that
and then she called me up and like once
I responded back she called and said I
totally apologize no it's good you never
made a move because I didn't have those
kind of feelings for you those weren't
my intentions I just was feeling lonely
I bought a new house I was all alone and
wanted somebody that I could trust over
so it was kind of like a relief off my
chest what yeah right because well in
that scenario you know the fact that you
made a video where you were legitimately
lost as to what you should do she sees
it and then it furthers the conversation
right so cut mission accomplished
correct like you've got to have some
examples of success
before we move to another all right I'm
not done with this story okay all right
because okay I now understand what you
said was I have to tone down my stories
because you wouldn't believe the full
truth because they get really crazy have
a hard time believing the story you just
told because I can't imagine that
happening in like a human universe say
no to a lot of opportunities that they
make movies about but why did she it
seems crazy to me that some girl I said
will you come and sleep in my bed with
me just be cut but I want I'm not gonna
tell you why yes but I don't expect
anything to happen and not say anything
no explanation can you come over I'm
gonna be like what anybody that gets
that phone call or Texas what are you
thinking you know yeah yeah yeah so
girls can be confusing but the more
females I hang out with the more I start
to understand how to speak female and
what are you learning about that I'm
learning that if you're talking with a
girl and she ever brings up any kind of
sex references or anything like that
there's normally a chance that she's
thinking about you more than just
friends if there's never any sexual talk
or if she's talking about sexual stuff
with about other guys friend-zoned and
what I like to do as soon as I sensed
I'm about to be in the friend zone
my friends on them before they can
friends it worked three empty something
yes agreed strike they sense it and they
want to take you out of the friend zone
it happens man we're funny creatures
human beings want what we can't have a
the way that you talk you're it's kind
of like you're a psychologist
sociologist on YouTube you know I think
my first impression was okay this guy's
an animator I know there's a video game
thing going on but then when I really
dig into your channel it's very much
about using your life I mean you you you
you characterize your channel to to us
instead of me trying to figure out dude
okay well it's just like we have a voice
on YouTube and a lot of us that have
over a few hundred thousand subscribes
we have a responsibility so I look at it
as I want to be the Big Brother to a lot
of little kids I want to be the guy
because we all represent something this
person represents white people this
person represents Jewish people I
represent black males so I want to give
guys a good name I want to give black
guys a good name I want to give
animators a good name people that live
in Florida we all represent different
when I approached my channel its yes on
the surface there's animation there she
talks about girls he talks about dates
and relationships but the more you dig
deep
I want to be like if I put enough
content and richness in here there has
replay value all up in it so you go down
deep enough and yes it's stories about
my life but there's messages in 90% plus
of my videos the next one coming up has
no message it's just me talking about my
first Hickey no messages whatsoever girl
I don't even know her name brought it
back to my house and got a hickey and I
figure I got to keep it keep you guys
guessing there's always a message this
time there's no message right it's just
a funny story yes correct now you've got
a lot of stories from your past like the
whole working at Disney type thing that
you're gleaning and putting into your
your channel is there a pressure to kind
of create stories in your life at this
point I didn't like fabricate no now
fabricate but let the living like I need
to do it act like this like I'm going to
be like four because we do good mother
good morning every weekday and a lot of
those are driven by our personal stories
things that happen to us that there is
this incentive on the weekend to how
well I should do something because
that's gonna lead to a story and I know
I have something and our lives are I
would say relatively boring we're gonna
take into account a little bit we're
working all the time we're married with
kids and so it's like it's not like
we're at some you know in some situation
on the weekends hurrying up in the club
with Jane right so in fact I even
remember just recently when we went to
4x4 hang in the valley
I specifically remember when Nick asked
you to drive and I was like I don't know
this is a good idea in real life but you
know what link driving is could lead to
a really good good mythical morning so
this is a good idea
I specifically remember think I was like
now my life is being impacted by maybe
we should your life choices we should
make a more risky choice because it
would lead to a better story but I'm
gonna hop into bed with this girl and do
nothing but face the wall because
is the best story you know I so
certainly not you fabricating stories
but in real life out in your head as
this happening in life that actually
happened a few weeks ago I I was gonna
keep this so under wraps so I'll give
you guys an exclusive a very short I
went to get my car serviced and as was
getting serviced I still had stuff to do
and the guy really liked my videos so
he's like dude I trust you I would you
take this nameless really expensive car
out and do what you need to do I'm on
turnpike I'm driving that I don't what
do you mean nameless car you're not
gonna name the car yeah I can't I don't
want to see him like oh he's just
bragging but about well it's not your
car right it was a nice car it's like
also mystique mystique is like a nice
little plot device so people might
picture net car I got Lamborghini
it could be Tesla could be alright
there's a bunch of nice cars out there
tell us the freaking car have you
wondering that okay story's over so I'm
driving on Turnpike and there's Ryu I'm
talking distractingly hot girl pulls up
next to me and then zooms off I'm just
like I could keep driving at the speed
limit or I could chase her and a good
story blog could come out of this is
what crossed your mind and I did it I
say yeah you did and some craziness went
down afterwards then I'm gonna make a
video about it yes things like that do
happen well art imitating life and
impact are interesting thing because you
know there's so many different elements
to this because you've got that like
okay how are my actions being changed by
how it's gonna impact my material but
then you got to go back to what we were
talking about a second ago which is the
example of the girl or the three
weekends and you know the friendzone
thing it worked itself out because she
saw the video now the people who are in
friendships or relationships with you
all right they know that you're gonna
talk about it it also changes the way
that they interact with you mm-hmm
now have you seen that happen yes it's
funny cuz I'll go on dates sometimes
kind of like a new form of gold the
thing is when we put stuff out there I
mean I'll get really personal with my
stories so sometimes I forget all those
stuff that I put out there
and I'll go on dates and girls will just
list off everything that I love and I'm
just like this is not good cuz one I
forgot that I put all this stuff out
there and two it's like they know like
if they act crazy enough I'll talk about
them in a video so I'll hear that
sometimes are you gonna talk about me in
your next video blog I'm just like is
that what we're on this day yeah it's
crazy
it's funny how and we talked to people
who have a lot of lag a lot but I don't
this is interesting dynamic with you
that I think that a lot of people just
kind of talk about themselves personally
maybe do some challenges but because you
have the advice angle and it involves
your interactions and observations with
other people and I think it might be
you've got more life experience than a
lot of vloggers because there's sort of
this like 18 to 22 year old vlogger
thing that's like a really popular thing
and the substance I think the substance
is really there and literally I think
about we have 16 seconds within the
first 16 seconds you have to say
something that you're gonna grab them
and when I go in here it's just like I
think we have again back to the
responsibility about these things it's
like you there's so many negative or
just not-so-great influences out there
in the music and TV and movies and all
this stuff all these you know ideas
popping into our head I'm just like you
know if I'm gonna take my time to get
out here and have a voice I want it to
be somewhat positive to work think about
consequences so when these three girls
walking to your hallway and you late at
night and you walk out of your hotel
we're like hey let's have a foursome you
start thinking you know consequences so
I mean that's a lot of things I try to
put into my videos sometimes
subliminally subliminally yeah sometimes
overtones sometimes undertones so as a
strategy even with that because I mean I
think if I can provide a voice I want it
to be somewhat positive to where I
listen all right you're gonna think
about consequences so when I get those
emails like dude I was left at my job
and I was gonna steal a hundred bucks
out of the register and then I remember
that story and they accused you of doing
this and this and this and this and I
was like see those are the kind of
stories that I love hearing because then
I know it's affecting people because my
friends in real life I give them advice
all the time they come asking for it and
they totally ignore it so I feel like I
just wasted an hour of that phone call
just this ask hole basically come in for
advice and then
yes but when I jump on YouTube I know
somebody's gonna benefit from that but
it's interesting to me that you you want
to make a positive impact and your it
seems like you're a great guy as much as
I'm gonna know you and certainly I've
gotten to know you through the videos
that you want to do that but a so maybe
a side effect of that is that that
actually works on YouTube one of the
things that I think Rhett and I had
extensive conversations about watching
your vlogs that's impacted our content
good mythical morning is you're very
funny but it's almost like the sincerity
quotient is a little higher it's like
the advice you give it needs to actually
be useful and then you're going to
deliver it in a funny way I feel like
you could and that's what works as
opposed to you could certainly I get the
impression go the whole comedic route I
mean you could you could go into
stand-up comedy you could say I could
tell the funniest story ever and it'd
just be funny and you do do some of that
but I we find it fascinating that that
since when you get the sincerity right
that there's actually you believe in
what you're saying and you're delivering
something that's useful and happen to
make it entertaining it just makes it
more palatable people have that desire
for that thing that I really want to
know about the friendzone I really want
to know about how to text and swoozie is
funny in the way that he talks about it
it's not just hey you got a you got to
watch this guy's funny videos cuz he's
funny first and that's what I was like
in that observation because literally
like I try so hard to keep it invisible
but at the same time in the foreground
and I wonder so many like hours I'm
spending and crafting this whole thing
like are they getting it like will
people see what's really going on and on
layer 4 so to hear you say that like
that makes it's like such a reward to
hear you say what you just said but yeah
man it's like really I care at the end
of the day like the people that have
never met that subscribe like I care so
I care if you get the girl like there's
so many times that I've been like in a
situation where I'm just crashing and
burning with a female and I learned so
much because I mean I was a lifeguard
and
animator that's like a crazy combination
a very powerful observation training
that's like most of my life I've been
doing those two things so it's like I
observe even how I do things
and we're clear sometimes guys are
clingers and we don't realize like
that's pushing the girl away so I want
you to get the girl I want the girl to
get the guy wants you to be as
successful in life in general so what
I'm telling you these things it's like I
literally am trying to affect your life
it's not just hahahaha that's great
because I've had a youtube video turn my
life around life turn my day around 20
was like really crappy mood watch a
video laugh that feeling in my chest I
want to give that to the viewer but it
also works better on YouTube that it is
useful and not just funny correct
so we observe that and then when you say
I want I want the guy to get the girl
kind of thing I also get the impression
that you're saying I want the guy to get
laid I don't think that's what you're
saying it's you want to you could you
kind of give a relationship advice you
want them to have a successful
relationship long term you're talking
about consequences you're talking about
you know like the dr. Phil type stuff
here and the three of us just run down
this hall and for whatever reason we
have to call nine-one-one now our
actions between the time that that call
is made up until the time the cops get
here will decide whether they're coming
to save us or to take us away mmm
plan is simple just off of the actions
that we've just done in those 5 to 10
minutes right so it's like I want people
to kind of get into that mindset because
I we don't act unless we think about it
unless it's reflexive like I'm I teach
on the knee and your leg kicks out
that's reflexive you have no control
over that but pretty much everything
else that we do we have control over and
there's a thousand decisions that we
make from the time we roll out of bed
and both those feet hit that ground
there's thousands of decisions that we
have to make from that time - let me get
back in the bed ok
well we want to get you know you I want
to find out what made you into the guy
that you are today that has this
perspective so and I know you've lived a
lot of life and and you also laid out a
lot of what you've what you've
experienced and you draw my life video
so people can kind of get more details
there too but tell us about growing up
the I was in Trinidad we got robbed
and it wasn't so bad getting
because you know Trinidad in parts we
have bad parts like everywhere else but
it was just you know people jumping our
fence and picking our mangoes in off the
tree but then when I'm waking up in the
middle of night and seeing random
strangers going through my drawers that
when we had to leave the island and I've
been in Orlando ever since so you like
rolled over give me the details I don't
know how I woke up but I remember
opening my eyes and I saw two guys that
I knew I didn't know going through my
stuff and it's just like okay bro we're
just gonna find underwear in there so
I'm not too concerned but please don't
stab me in my sleep like that's like the
first memory I can remember going back
my entire life was opening my already
traumatic yeah and my thing was as a kid
I remember thinking if I scream he might
kill me if I go to sleep he might kill
me but I'm gonna go with option two kind
of thing I don't know how much that's
affect you play possum yeah pretty much
um I think I made me a little paranoid
because now like I honestly when I buy a
TV I chop up that box in the little
pieces because I don't want it to sit by
the end of my road because all my
neighbors now know that I have a 42 inch
Samsung in my house that might be a long
term effect but um I think what's really
gotten me into the person that I am
today
was I just literally I think a lot like
it when I'm in the shower when I'm on
long road trips I think I think you
should it's something's always going on
up there and girls like to hurt me
people like take advantage of me and
it's just like I really wish there was
some way to stop this like can I at
least like pull it back to where doesn't
hurt is bad like can I be colder like
what can I do so I remember this point
in life like I just want to like end it
all and there was some girl my first
girl love at first sight tall it I made
a bit about video about this suicidal
thoughts and I remember getting so
heartbroken when was this I was 18 okay
so we head over heels in love with this
girl and she was like you know I'm tired
of you by the way I've been dating
Hector for the last month Hector
devastated and and his name was Hector
it was Hector tang and the last thing I
remember was going home and grabbed my
dad's gun and really yeah I just raged
blacked out and I woke up the next
morning like I think I was staring down
the barrel of that gun
but you weren't going to shoot Hector no
no I don't know why I should have been
thinking about him but yeah and he's
like I mean you blacked out but you were
going to shoot yourself probably I those
are the thoughts in my head like you
know what what's the point of going I
hurt so much right now what's the point
of going on and I remember thinking like
you know what there's so much more to be
happy about like there's people that
would kill to be in my situation right
now that don't have food that don't have
shells fed don't have a lot of things so
I think that was like a turning point in
my life too whereas like thinking like
in my own head you know what no I would
have shot myself over some girl and
there's millions of those out there so
literally it was just like you know I
can be a better person I think that was
like one of the turning points in my
life and thank God it happened at that
point as opposed to later on because I
have heard stories of friends who are
cops who have seen suicides or walked
onto the scene of suicides over some
girl so right I think that's probably
like the pentacle moment in my life
where was like I can be a better person
and I want to actually every day get on
that journey of being a better person
and was it a was it about be becoming
better relationships I know that from
general everything better at same thing
like better black person a better life
guard a better person at work like no
matter what job I have I want to be the
best not in competition with you or you
or any co-worker but I want to be the
best at myself so I can't like I pretend
I have a twin sometimes even when I'm
working on videos alright I know he's
gonna work on a video about Disney I'm
gonna work on the video about Disney I'm
gonna pretend I've seen his script so
look at a finished script in black okay
I have to I'll do this now so I'm in
competition with myself I'm pretty much
everything I do just to be the best
version for to go back to girls a lot of
my female friends boyfriends do not like
me because when I take that girl out I'm
happy that you're spending time with me
I have flaky friends a lot of us have
flaky friends who just ditch on us who
bailed on us and they're unreliable
you're giving me your time I'm gonna
make sure we go out to Chili's and you
don't spend a dime when we go out and
make sure you have the best possible
time I spend a lot of time taking notes
on this stuff and then then you had a
lot of trouble I mean from your drama
life video you had a lot of trouble
fitting in
as a kid it seemed like you moved to
different schools and yeah we're like
socially a little bit awkward and I
think that's how we fit so well on
YouTube because there's a lot of
socially awkward kids who really don't
have a voice so when they come across
our channel like this guy's awkward just
like me
so I think that's also part of it too
but um but that but the girl who dumped
you when you're 18 that was and that may
have been a particularly low point but I
get the impression that there were lots
of low points relationally for you that
you weren't some player who was well I
got this figured out I'm just gonna tell
you about it you're kind of having gone
through the fire so to speak seemed to
be speaking from that because I wish
sometimes like literally sometimes I'm
thinking about what video we're topic to
talk about next or what to put in a
video I think I wish I had somebody
around me that had knowledge like a big
brother to say X so when I'm going
through it boom he just said this so if
I'm bumping my head like bro my big
brother just told me not to do this and
I have cousins who they don't have the
same morals that I do they don't say no
a lot and they've gone through hundreds
of female interactions and some of the
stuff that these guys say blow my mind
but they're absolutely right and I take
that and kind of mesh it into I apply it
to see if it works and nine times out of
ten it does and then I kind of share it
with some of the YouTube audience
because those guys are players those
guys hands down like they were walking
to a club
who who are players my cousins okay and
I mean we all have the same kind of
facial features so we all look like
different versions of the same guy and
they'll walk into a club and they'll
find the hottest girl another little tip
here for you guys exclusive they'll find
the hottest girl in the club and I want
to take her home but they'll stand back
the whole night and watch every guy in
the club make a pass at her and then
they'll intentionally go by brushed up
against the grandma oh sorry yeah ah
when she makes that reaction he's like
babe relax you're a 5 at best and they
say at that point that you either get
punched or slapped or cursed out but by
the end of the night they get the girl's
number it's totally a move and these are
the kind of guys that I'm talking to and
this
like they know their stuff man it's like
any girl you're five at best and I girls
like oh I spent an hour on this eyeliner
and concealer think in their head so
other guys are coming with the same
approach like oh my god you're so help
me buy you a drink better than that
there's other guys you're a five at best
relax
Wow have you tried and so you've you've
tried this a variation tough love is
kind of how I do it like yeah I put it
in one of the texting videos how to text
a girl I believe mmm and when you meet
that girl you can't blow her because imp
like inside we want back oh my god thank
you so much for spending the time taking
me out and we want to do that when we
get home but don't do that because every
guy does that so kind of like I take
what my cousin said and basically is
like everybody every guy treats a girl
like this in the club you be that one
guy that doesn't cheer like that so I'll
take that and kind of translate it into
every guy text like this you be that one
guy that stands out and doesn't text
like that um if we're to go back to your
drama life which was great he's very
insightful yeah it's like a cheat sheet
for ear biscuits I love that draft twice
not to start from the beginning it was
oh really oh but go on um one of the
things I wanted to ask you about was at
one point you go into an analogy I think
when you're talking to planes going yeah
going from public school to private
school to public school and you give us
a girl there was a girl that you met
that said something that made you think
about something in the airplane and now
at the airplane it is those who haven't
seem to draw my life basically she was
saying we're talking about a
conversation about God and I love those
kind of deep conversations where you
don't end up talking like this you know
when you're arguing and she was like
there is no reason that an airplane
should fly but you make this rule and
you make this rule and you make this
rule and then the impossible happens
like you curved the wing here and you
curve this metal here because it's like
two tons of like weight flying through
the air at 500 miles an hour and she was
like the same way with life like if
there's no reason a plane should be able
to fly but in life there's no reason you
should be able do XYZ but if you do this
and this and this and this you can do
the impossible and I was like holy crap
like the gift of the guy going
and is blame alone so yeah that that
stuck with me for a long time and so
what was your application of that just
in life it's like okay so for example
when people come at you like really mad
normally we want to respond really mad
back so sometimes it's like you can't
always do what your impulse is to do so
that's kind of one of the things I mean
I've popped my head you guys for me on
the spot with this when I wasn't
expecting that
um but yeah in life it's like not always
doing what you want to do like when a
girl breaks your heart it's talking
trash about you behind your back like
you want to get back at her and do this
but you know what I'm gonna be the adult
here and act like that because people
get really bitter I don't know if you
guys have ever been through really bad
breakups but I know how how you handle
them but it's always best to be the
adult no matter what goes down and I
think that's part of the thing is like
really thinking your thoughts through
the conclusions cuz we I love this girl
I'm gonna move in with her and then
we're gonna do this and we're gonna do
that and then you realize like this girl
is psychotic
but you ignored all the signs so
thinking your duster before you actually
act on them so yeah I thought I'm sorry
I felt like in trying to like decipher
the plain analogy I know that you were
kind of talking about being in a private
school I guess it was a Christian school
you were talking about the Bible and
like talking about beliefs I thought you
were making a connection to kind of
making a religious realization there's
different kind of ways you can go about
it cuz I mean look at like this - um I
give 10% of everything I get off of
youtube to my church and my family hates
that there's like you're an idiot like
what you're giving all this money to
your church I'm just like guys well I
remember if you look at it they say okay
well there's stuff that I talk about in
the Bible if you want to see if it's
true and I think there's a lot of stuff
you can apply and test so like if right
give 10% of my earnings they say it's
like planting a seed and that plant will
plant ten more seeds and those 10 seeds
will plant 10 don't know that so so
basically at a certain point your life I
guess you were you were at a at a school
where you were taught Christian faith
like Baptists okay and so but you were
learning to test that for yourself can
determine if it was true there was one
question a lot of the questions that I
had for the teachers they could never
answer so
was one thing I was not a huge fan of
and my grandfather is a pastor of a
church and let's just say I have one you
guys really fast backwards he cheated on
my grandmother with his secretary who
was younger than my mom he's a pastor
the church and I have an uncle who's
three years younger than me hmm so you
got to rewind the caffeine put that all
together yeah and like for the longest
he was the beacon of hope in my family
I'm just like he represented Christian
faith and yet he's running around this
and a lot of congregation like really
didn't know exactly the whole story
hooking up with somebody a secretary
younger than his daughter and you're
married doing all this
Brenton so it's just like really bro
you're I'm not gonna be like that guy no
way and I think a lot of people that
really have our approach faith in a
certain kind of mentality have had
examples like that in their life but
sure let's pretend that when we do now
we have to answer to God or somebody I
don't want to be like you know what I
didn't follow you because of that guy
and I don't think that was a good enough
excuse so it's like right let me start
testing some of the stuff so even going
back to that giving the 10% and the
planning and plan that I really didn't
have money to be giving 10% when I was
working as a lifeguard but I won't do it
anyway and now just through YouTube you
know following the whole plant the seed
seed seed seed I'm making what I made a
year every 20 days now whether it be you
- whether it be whatever sponsor videos
I make of a one sponsor video from
YouTube I get what I would've got as a
lifeguard working for three years on one
sponsor video that's three minutes long
so it's just like again I test like if I
told you guys right now all right you
guys rented a car it's outside and all
the tires are slashed how would you test
to see if what I'm saying is true you
drive it exactly are you at least gold I
probably just look at it exactly you're
gonna go and test this I'll just hear it
and like that's wrong because the next
question is how do you tell if what
somebody is telling you is truth or
false it's like sometimes people are
really convincing you know but we can't
just go off of you know I think Honda's
are crap I'm not gonna drive them let me
go give it a test drive that's kind of
how I approach things not just that
Honda's crap I'm done kind of thing even
though you lose
examples of how we can look at things
like uh I'd only want to go I'll stop
there cuz you guys will get me on a rant
and I won't be able to stop but go on go
on
you can read no it's just I've always
been the kind of person that I want to
test I want to see if what's going on is
true because we have to answer for our
actions we have to answer for the things
we say and sometimes what we think so we
think normally translates to how we act
and you know things along those lines so
I just well again want to make sure to
be the best possible version of myself
that I possibly can be and I can
challenge at least people through my
videos to do that or be that I found it
interesting that the the test for your
faith in the face of what happened with
your grandfather mm-hmm was a financial
test mm-hmm that's for any one of them
one of many okay so I mean it's just
like cuz at the same time too if you
look at the good book there are guys who
are like trying to do right and they're
having really crappy lives and it's just
like I shouldn't have to test this to be
like all right if I have a good life I'm
doing it right if I have a bad life I'm
doing it wrong there should be something
in there too where it's almost like if
my hand is like rotting like gangrene
and everything but I'm telling
rhettandlink like guys my arm is fine
you guys can look at my arm and be like
yeah your arm is not okay where I could
smell it you know so it's kind of like
applying things like that to my life to
where yes bad things are gonna happen to
me my mom's gonna die my dad's gonna die
no matter how good of a person I am bad
things are gonna happen so not use that
as my scale but at the same time if I do
good things good things will come back
to me in kind of like a weird Karma but
you know circle of life Lion King
reference kind of thing well it seems
like you are very much you value
experience yes because when you say
tests your your what's really saying is
like trying something you know you
implement something and you see if it
works and you do that in your in your
life and then when it works for in but
it also it moves beyond things like you
know morality but it moves into the the
mechanics of dating right you know the
mechanics of friendships and
relationships and then you try something
you learned something and then you turn
it around and put it
back into a video I don't know there's a
question there it's really just an
observation that's something that's kind
of coming together right now I just find
it interesting that you you're so
focused on the experience and then you
bring that to YouTube attack I really
honestly cannot think of someone else
who's doing it in the same way and I was
actually looking at that too like i
before I started out on the YouTube
thing my 3 G's my 3g network god gaming
and girls so if you look at all my
videos they all touch on at least one or
all three of those topics so I want to
make sure I stayed on path to where if I
do one day blow up they have a lot of
money and you know people working for me
I still have that kind of 3G network to
kind of keep me balanced because at the
same time I don't want to be all over
the place for the same time to like even
with you guys we get pressured - we got
a viral video people want to see that
all the time so it's just kind of like I
looked at it as give the people what
they want to see whether they know they
want to see it or not and a lot of times
you there's a lot of reading of the
comments a lot of listening when people
say how do they react to certain videos
and my dad told me when I had about
10,000 subscribers he was just like
which kind of videos do people react to
the most and I told my story ones she's
like okay well keep doing that and his
other thing that he was saying too was
get the female demographic no matter
what you do get the females because when
you walk into a girl's room and her room
is covered from head to toe in one
direction and Justin Bieber that's
normal
well you're not gonna find a lot of
13-year old guys with their room covered
from head to toe any Cathy they're very
fanatical so he's like get those girls
and talk about stories and that's your
perfect storm right this is your dear
dad give me advice and the thing was he
was the biggest hater out of everybody
around me he'll like it's not gonna work
anything I want to do throughout my
entire life he was the one I was like
what you want to do oh you want to be a
screenwriter not gonna work if to go to
school for like 16 years to do that
anything and he'd constantly ask and how
it's like that whole idea don't let
somebody else tell you what you can and
can't do because I started hearing his
voice as my internal dialogue like I
wanna but yeah I can't and it was like
no I'm not gonna let them put their
limitations on me I know of my
limitations are I'm gonna try to exceed
all of them so now I mean I'm making
more than both my parents combined from
my bedroom they have to wake up at Sue's
o'clock every morning
and they're probably gonna hear this
podcast so but yeah and that's the
situation where it's at right now I mean
and people through my life have been
like hating I mean the friends and
family those are the ones that were not
really the biggest supporters but
they've slowly start to come around now
so do you have a gaming channel though
yes Michelle Phan um I had 30,000
subscribers I met Michelle Phan through
a mutual friend and she loves video
games but she can never really talk
about it on her beauty channel right so
we met at a party one time in LA and
Sue's bet way back dude it was 2010 okay
and she was like let's just start a
channel together and it blew up both of
our channels like a lot of the guys that
I mean even though I only have 30,000
subscribers like it was a trending thing
on Twitter on YouTube for a good amount
of days so she got a lot of traffic I
got a lot of traffic and they became
really hard to keep running press Start
really quickly so we kind of just left
it cuz at the time nobody was doing
Let's Plays nobody was doing let me know
buddy with over 10,000 subscribers yeah
so we had to jump through so many
hurdles to get like gameplay up on the
screen you're talking on licensing yeah
like literally we had to have permission
slips like it's not like it is now yours
join a network and boom you're good to
go back then I had to like I had friends
at Capcom I had friends with Dead or
Alive I had friends in all the gaming
circles type like hey can we have
permission to play Halo da da da yeah I
just need you to sign off on this boom
and YouTube wanted us to submit videos
weeks in advance before we could upload
really yeah they had as you were trying
to do it by the book and there were
people who were starting to just do it
yeah or at least later they started you
know a low number account of view it's
like this is before PewDiePie like PDP
and I started our channels at the same
time and then the gaming stuff was just
too hard to maintain in you know
conjunction with our own personal
channels with the way that you were
doing it correct by the rock I was not
getting sleep
it was so bad like and with the press
start we had every Friday was our day
and so now but and so now you don't do
it now yeah now it's just like look at
it as a bonus level like you're playing
Legend of Zelda and you have a bonus
mission look at press star as that is
kind of how we put it to where it was
but with the success of it why aren't
you saying I'm going
back into this I mean oh I want to at
times but at the same time I feel so
driven to keep doing the Siouxsie
channel because I've had ideas for a
very long time but I didn't want to put
them out there because I felt like
there's not enough eyes here if I'm
gonna spend a week editing this and only
10,000 people see it and that's not
worth it but now like as an artist the
only thing you really want well the
first big thing is an audience hmm and
now I have that so it's like I feel so
driven to the point to where I don't get
much sleep because I'm still thinking
like okay I need to put something out
for these guys so well if you got a guy
like Toby Turner who is you know become
so popular for his comedy videos and
then all of a sudden he starts tobyGames
and that moves up into the top 10 10 or
whatever I mean this trend even has guys
like us thinking about you know I doubt
we'll ever do it because it would be so
off-brand but I'm saying it like it has
that gaming is pulled it has such a
great pool because it seems like oh man
it's just this easy view you can get
which leads to easy money right I know a
guy making six figures a month on
YouTube I'm gonna show you guys it's not
crazy to you guys but listeners like six
figures playing video games yeah oh yeah
from your bedroom well listen we're not
gonna tell you how to run your business
but it is curious that someone who is
such a such a great fit you only have so
many hours in the day I started you
don't want to see a decrease in the
swoozie channel with what you got going
on there so you need tough man a lot of
my creative juices go into that like you
guys should see like my little editing
room I have like dry erase boards over
here in another wall just for you no
dialogue to put in videos so there's
like a mad scientist room where this
video next in that video in this video
and all these others like dialogues and
ones and phrases over here so I mean
it's literally I feel like I was put on
this earth to entertain like I literally
felt that for a very long time so
YouTube was never in the equation but I
kept putting energy into it because I
looked at it as I can keep working on my
craft because I want to do film I want
to do editing and a lot of us in YouTube
we all want to do that big picture thing
and that's why we do YouTube but dude
it's the best job I've ever had in my
entire life that I couldn't even it is
pretty great
now before
started recording when we were just kind
of getting settled we were talking about
the Howard Stern nature of well that's
what you said you're like it's like well
this is this is gonna be honest it's
gonna be an hour of us just talking
about you you were like okay get Howard
Stern on you on you okay and you're like
well I'll talk about anything I'm a book
waiting to be open direct and then you
said except for two things
uh-huh and now I'm like you know what
yeah what are the two that means he's
broke I got to keep you guys in suspense
oh so he just did two things I was in
the bathroom at that point yeah you were
in the bathroom it's funny I've ever
give me half of one thing cuz I'm sorry
yeah we got a little bit on religion we
got a lot on relationships and then
what's the other one politics I don't
honestly bro I don't follow too much
politic okay so it's not that I mean we
can play the guessing game or we can
just get real we can get well the thing
too is I remember one time just to
quickly touch on what you were talking
about um sex ed class in fifth grade the
teacher walks in he was like there's one
question that somebody's gonna ask in
here I'm wondering who it's gonna be
okay so this is a penis is gonna happen
and I'm just like holy crap what's that
one question so we're in the class of
like 30 minutes and then I'm like you
couldn't even tell us if we ask that
question and some kid was like so I have
a question teacher how do you make twins
and he answers a question and it goes by
the way that was the question what
awesome it's such that it wasn't me but
I'm so happy now that I know and
actually that's not a great question I
said I really don't I don't care how to
make he wins you do it twice and in
close proximity I always want to be a
twin I don't know about you guys well I
so much so much so that you've created
an imaginary twin that you compete
against I will say in biology class we
had a substitute one day and I just
thought it would be better to ask to
substitute because she wouldn't be back
the next day and she was subbing in
biology so there's she should do a
little self it by the way it's like I
don't have a counter but I don't have to
ask this awkward question and then see
this woman Miss Lee cuz I believe
miss Lee was out woman comes in little
yeah yeah I don't know if you remember
me asking the question but I asked do
you and you can read what you wanted to
this question but my question to her was
do you have a set amount of sperm or are
you constantly producing sperm and I
don't mean you teacher who's a female I
mean me like there's a man have a set
number of sperm and what'd she say
you asked this in front of the whole
class yeah and she said I can't believe
I don't remember this all right I don't
I don't think I don't think she knew
you're afraid you're gonna run out I was
afraid that it would make some changes I
was gonna run out before I got you know
to that point to go time yeah yeah
didn't really count it
and she was like I don't I think you're
constantly producing it mm-hmm
but I was just so concerned that I had
to ask have you guys ever had a
distractingly hot teacher oh yeah yes
what did you get a Smith the freshman
English as freshmen in high school or a
freshman in high school
you know the ladies you talking you say
I was in the same class like where'd you
guys get in that class grade wise I got
a boner in that class that distracting
that me I had a teacher one time I
failed because every tiwa emailing I
wanted to impress man because that's it
that was my application my applications
English I'm gonna make her think I am
the smartest kid in here man so I opened
up I think I'm gonna you know we kind of
changed something about I opened up a
little bit I asked an awkward question
in biology class which I just told you
mmm-hmm getting me to open up for all
you know I might not have to things like
you might just invent dad I just said it
yeah you just tore him in my brain and
never know please tell me it's laters
bro layers let me ask you this okay your
your charisma is infectious your you
know your you are a gifted entertainer I
can see this and butter
okay but all of this is true there's you
know everyone in their life goes through
the dark times you know and or formed by
that I know that relationally there's
those things is there something else
there formative that as in like a
negative kind of thing yeah yeah okay
well that okay I never drink ever up
until like two years ago okay and the
battle for me a lot of times is I try to
be a good person by the same time I
don't want to live my life like trying
to ride this straight line to where I
miss out on everything and I remember
the first time that I drank I had never
been drunk that I'm not trying to get to
hugging a toilet and vomiting all night
not trying to get there is this going
along the lines of what you were just
asking me sure um and we're gaming
convention yeah I think might have been
packs or something like that and then
afterwards there was this really cute
guitar hero Asian girl and she was just
like I'm gonna buy you a shot and I just
said yes and I don't know like literally
the needle scratch on the club and
everybody turned her like what like five
shots just showed up on my my table and
I'm like I'm gonna take three of these
and then I'm done and I took those shots
and I was sitting like what do people
keep talking about drinking like this is
disgusting one I feel like I just drank
death and it's really not a big deal so
then my boy was like all right are you
ready to go and I go yes and the hall
room said and then every girl in that
bar looked like a supermodel get me that
I gotta here right now
I drink on special occasions and then
usually I stopped at three shots and the
drink is gonna be patron that I messed
with this is information I've never fed
out yeah but you turn the page and you
want us to know and that sometimes I
wonder like last night there was a party
here mmm
and I didn't drink a drop and I was
really bored I'm like is this because I
wasn't having a good time or
because I hadn't have a drop of alcohol
so things like that I really try to like
analyze now by the same time to like in
the Christian faith well you said
Baptists right yes I think specifically
Baptist there's this with the dog you
can't drink it all like we were we went
to a Baptist Church at a young age and
then kind of switched out of that but it
was so that was something that we saw
was a difference and liked about it so I
mean we would you you said that you had
the 3 G's God being the first one so you
seem to be a devout Christian let my
grandfather I mean I'm sure it wasn't
like one day he was awesome and the next
day he's sleeping with multiple girls
I'm sure it was this gradual kind of
progression into that so I try to make
sure to pay attention to a lot of my
actions and things that I do because
when I told you guys her story it can
get interpreted a bunch of different
ways so I really try to lay no kind of
bottleneck it to where a good
storyteller can control the audience if
he wants you to not like a character
boom he wants you like a character boom
so I even try to put that in a lot of
the things I talked about at the same
time I want you guys to get the real me
and with 2 million subscribers you're
gonna have some people that you offend
when you talk about alcohol or when you
talk about all these different topics or
I made out with a girl and I didn't even
know her name you're gonna like you're a
bad influence for my kids in that but at
the same time too you can't keep coming
at then just knocking on their door hey
let's talk about this you can't come out
in the same way it's 2014
so essentially like I'm really trying to
get to your kids and give them a
positive message but not the same way
they've got it a hundred times before so
right now I'm really thinking about just
even my own actions even up until this
day like me drinking okay well there's
about 100 people at that party they
probably saw me this and this and this
that net and that so right now I really
try to make sure that my actions line up
with my words so there's never a gradual
kind of thing that goes into that and I
will also say on this podcast is I think
I have a really addictive personality so
the things that I like I do a lot right
and I know me so that's why I normally
only stick to patron because I hate that
stuff
if I found an alcohol that I like I'd be
in trouble let me tell you guys that
right now so with video games I think
even with editing
I can spend 18 hours editing because I
have an addictive personality I grow
into this and do it you got lost in it
right when you're trying to juxtapose or
have this you know you've got God as a
priority you got girls as a priority and
you want to be an influence but yet you
know when you're you're talking about
these two worlds there seems to be it
seems to be a clash of the worlds direct
you tell me well I want to be very
devout but I want to get the girl mm-hmm
so how do I get is that where you end up
sleeping with a girl and literally just
sleeping with her I had sex I'm a virgin
so I think that's another thing to
waiting for me and that oft I think my
friends tell me this is why they don't
do your fans already know that yes I
think a lot of my friends tell me that
girls end up cheating on me is because
you know we're getting all romantic oh
that always worked them up and then they
run out with this other guy because
they're all wound up and they need to
you know get their fix because most of
the girls I get with aren't virgins so
now they know what they're missing and
what I find very interesting is after
they get with the next guy and we're
done
they come crawling back like okay
because the thing is in for plate
there's soap sucking toes like not to
say that I do or don't cuz I keep that
right that line in my videos I mention
it a lot but I don't finish you talk
about sucking toes unless I throw it out
there and the comments go crazy do you
do you or don't you suck toes but I
throw it out there answered like knee
pits oh I never said that this is a
really good tell you like this is
probably the best podcast last interview
I've had ever that's a great endorsement
me pick all right oh yeah you'd like to
meet this here's the knee and the part
behind the knee is the knee pit when you
lick that guy's there are some girls
that will go crazy but there's so many
guys that are so anxious to just finish
the fight get to that you know that end
point video game time another another
pit right they missed that hole there's
there's so many floors to foreplay that
they miss so when the girl runs off with
another guy and he's not concerned about
your toes your knee pit your neck your
ear he's not gonna say about any of that
other stuff what about the armpit no I
never mess with yeah yeah that stay away
[Music]
yeah and then they experienced that and
they get what they think they want then
it's just like Dante really showed my
body a lot of attention like I will
massage you for an hour like I go it's a
two-part play like literally like I am
one person on the stage and you're the
next person on the stage and usually the
bed is the stage you know and we're just
kind of you know is it thespians that's
the right word right yeah like an actor
yeah we're thespians on this stage and I
want to make sure to give the best
performance every single time and if the
actors are both women's and lesbian I
think a lot of guys don't put that
attention into it so that's where they
normally come crawling back like to lie
to you for those months and then she'd
on you and then lie some more can you I
think they like that the back of my
knees and that basically what they're
saying by the same time like again
people were here this invictus who's a
guy he is so into himself by the same
time like that's just what it is so I
really think about the when you've
limited yourself yeah to not going all
the way then you've got two places if I
keep on just the stage I'm doing a bad
thing like when we're acting I want to
run out into the audience I mean I
literally the creativity doesn't stop
just at YouTube I'll just say that no
one of the things I'm kind of reading
between the lines here is that you you
talk about multiple girls when it comes
to your videos and you're kind of
talking about girls plural in general so
is there ace is there a special someone
know at the moment and why not oh I
think I haven't found mrs. right yet and
the problem is a good problem to have is
I have a lot of hot friends a lot and
then YouTube is only making that good
problem worse because again now with
talking about stages YouTube becomes a
stage and the world can see it so I mean
I have girls from Norway and USSR and
Australia and Australia has some
amazingly hot girls and I mean that
would Skype being a thing
kick being a thing and whatsapp
literally well you know college in 1980
is not college in 2014 like I could be
hollering at a girl in Norway like any
girl becomes like above fate so not to
say that that's how I kind of look at it
but girls approach you when you're on
YouTube and they send you pictures they
ask because they know what I'm about on
YouTube that's like hey what kind of
pictures can I send you and especially
now with you know snapchat being what it
is they know that I tried I try to run
the straight arrow so they ask the kid
maybe m.a or nc-17 I'm like let's keep
on pg-13 cuz you just never know like my
one of my biggest fear is cos you guys
are getting so much I don't know now one
of my biggest fears but i'ma let you
know this I'm putting it out there cuz
I'm aware of it is that there's gonna be
a underground YouTube channel
who gets girls cast them and then it
goes after youtubers and when exposes
the entire process we should produce
this channel you can have it bro it
sounds kind of sleazy I know well can
you explain it producer under our
underground brand so what were they dark
with Oh we'll have a girl and she'll be
like a 10k who's who's our topic here
we're good we got a knock out ten
youtubers you got a knock them out fast
because they're gonna talk so let's go
look at PewDiePie Tobi swoozie and I
don't know DeStorm and then she
documented the whole process correct you
know that she all of you all of us are
behind the phone literally like a
production yeah yeah
start with a simple text or a simple
Facebook because there are some guys out
there who just like literally don't
answer emails unless you're hot
so we'll just send that hot one out
there and be like that up we got a bite
we got a nibble okay so he sent this and
it's all documents it was like to catch
a youtuber yes Prince Chris Hanson to
hoax total jam that's swoozie will host
and will produce you would get these
guys really bad slash good I think about
that well yourself I think you're saying
maybe you were there before yourself
aware that something happened to me so
when I get these emails from these tens
I'm like
rhett and Link could be behind
I think sometimes like even all my
interactions a lot of times I use my
cousin's advice when the hot girls like
oh my gosh you're so great I just say
thanks send because any other guy when
they see that email oh my god how'd you
find my videos and don't know and just
go crazy on them dude I'm just like you
know what thanks I just sometimes a
sturdy and I try to interact with guys
and girls right but I look you have
something you want to say oh I think to
me it's full circle with you talking
about consequences I think for yourself
you know that you're in a position with
the type of content relationship content
that you put out there that there's
women who are approaching you there's
actually a couple of things that work
here mm-hmm I think you you sense that
you're kind of you've set a high
standard for yourself that's almost a
dare
if for girls to say if I can get swoozie
all right he's a virgin mm-hmm I want to
be that one I've had girls spreading
rumors that they've had sex with me and
that never happened hmm
like that's a thing now it's like are
you kid this is my life yeah so again a
story for a movie where the girl is
lying about the guy having sex and he
won't this is my life and I think the
second part full circle is you're
putting into play you put it into
practice what you're saying about
consequences and you're talking about
Rhett link maybe behind this this text
from a 10 or some ma pictures you know
it's what what are the consequences
worst case scenario so I mean my I've
had when I worked with DIRECTV I've had
those producers like those guys helped
me and mentored me a lot and they told
me like from Jump Street 2007 like Susan
you're gonna be big like we don't know
what you have planned for the future but
we can just see how you walk around the
set and talk and you're on camera you're
gonna be big so here's what you need to
do they take me into the truck out back
and like listen treat every text like
it's gonna go viral treat every message
and email like it's gonna go viral XYZ
LMNOP and it's like wow at first i
ignored a lot of that stuff like if a
girl wants to send me pictures I won't
take them you know that kind of thing
but when you really think about like
these guys have been in the industry for
a very long time so when I start
thinking you know what this girl is like
saying and talking really slick maybe I
should text it back but I'm gonna treat
this like it's going viral so let me now
change what I was going to say and say
something else so you just never know
man okay so we got one of them which was
King behind the knees yeah yeah yeah
yeah one thing what's the other one
is that for the second podcast when I
come back I gotta give you guys our to
your audience wanting more okay that's
the secret oh this has been a good part
one this has been amazing that was it
the swoozie ear biscuit you know he uh
he's full of advice you know he this
what he does on the Internet he's Asafa
chol guy he's got this the way that he
talks about things is well okay let me
tell you the way that I see or the way
I've always thought of it or here's an
analogy for to explain that our here is
a little three G little acronym that
I've come up with from my life
philosophy I would say he's got like the
motivational speaker gene yes you know
right I could definitely see him doing
that you know I mean he talks about that
whole fearing the development of a show
called to catch a youtuber I think he
should be thinking more even format him
what he's basically the Dear Abby of
YouTube he could do something even more
in that format I mean he didn't ask me
but the producer and me is like okay
let's get less this whole ability to
encapsulate things in in terms of
comedic but meaningful advice I think
that can be formatted even further
swoozie if you're well if you're
listening to her own dear little skit is
listen to is only or biscuit but I think
it's working pretty well for him get
worst of all one interesting dynamic as
we discussed thoroughly that might
affect this whole Dear Abby plan is the
fact that most of everything that he has
a lesson about comes from a specific
experience so there is this dynamic and
we experience this too it's one of the
reasons that on good mythical morning we
don't always tell personal stories
because you run out of them you know
that's what we started going to articles
and lists and other things or like we
said with you adopt a lifestyle of
creating experiences for the sake of the
story right you know I was told a few
years ago by a friend of mine who I
think we're gonna ensure to make videos
and he said you know don't forget it's
always better to have a good story than
a good time and he was right if you're
an entertainer yes well and we talk
about that all the time if we're going
to do something and we begin to
contemplate making a stupid decision
about something like should we rent
these scooters will we possibly die say
well heck we'll be able to talk about it
on good mythical morning so we might as
well just do it I don't know what kind
of impact that has on our lives I know
that it's a slippery slope of
recklessness is what it sounds like no
but I'm saying that with with swoozie
there there's this thing that he is
living a life that he has chosen to make
public the people who are close to him
in his life their lives are going to be
made public in a entertaining way that
apparently most of them are comfortable
with it's an interesting dynamic and
he's doing that particular thing just
about as well as anybody on the Internet
and we had a good time talking to him
thanks to swoozie for sharing some
things that he didn't intend on sharing
talking about things that I love it like
we say all the time when somebody says I
didn't know I was gonna talk about this
then we know that we're doing something
right and be having a good time
let's woozi know what you think of his
ear biscuit it's swoozie but the eye is
a number one SW double-o z1e
let him know what you think of his ear
biscuit I see his icon right now is uh
Aladdin that's interesting you know he
doesn't look like Aladdin you see it
maybe a little bit sure that's right one
yeah it's definitely him he's he's
following us YouTube Partner pajama
model former Disney employee time
traveler music and film lover that is
him he barely has an identity crisis and
thinks he's Aladdin
maybe there's something we're missing
maybe there's another video we need to
watch or maybe you need to watch it
after being introduced to swoozie also
let us know what you think hashtag ear
biscuits on Twitter be sure to leave a
review on iTunes we always appreciate
that
and we'll have another one of these next
week you can count on us yes
can we count on you well so I believe we
can
[Music]
[Music]